when you think the next step what do you
want to do you see that or not don't do
anything until you know you know the way
people say money burns the holy pocket
and they really mean you just want to
buy some fresh gear actually a lot of
times it's in this scenario where you're
like what do I invest in I want to do it
proper Don't Force It but keep looking
for [__] that excites you to get into do
you like selling things yeah then find
things to sell if someone's lucky enough
to like selling things then they just
keep having to find things that they
like to sell sneakers wasn't a thing
that people sold when I was a kid now
it's [__] real sports cards nfts
clothes it could be something left field
but find something you want to sell